we are here with the goodbye promise
dream team mr. Richard Jacob and mr.
Gregor Collins I'm Gregor and we just
got off the air right now with the
brilliant and amazing Aaron crumley four
eyed monsters and open in D as well as
other projects and um we just had a
consultation kind of an open forum to
talk about goodbye promise and I want to
get your guys thoughts on that what do
you what do you think of today's
consultation he had some just amazing
insights Gregor I'll actually Richard
jacob i loved it i thought it was that
it was an amazing experience and things
that we learned just about everything
that he said was just unbelievable
there's a lot of things you would think
we would think about what we just never
did and I thought it was amazing
especially the the ideas fee for getting
the fans to interact with us and that is
that was just amazing I thought it was
an extremely helpful i'm very impressed
with with this guy and he he just
everything he says is so pertinent and
so honest and it's so usable and i think
a lot of the stuff he said i would i
would love to do for our campaign and i
wish we could have more time i wanted to
ask him about international distribution
because i think i think indie filmmakers
are kind of blind i did they don't know
how to market their film overseas and
when what what tools to use and so I
think he I think a whole show could be
dedicated to that I don't know why would
I just I had a great time and I went by
so quickly because he he had so many
good things to say so great